hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
a principios de la semana pasada el
enclave español de ceuta estuvo en los
ojos del mundo por una avalancha
migratoria sin precedentes al territorio
llegaron al menos 8.000 personas desde
marruecos entre hombres algunas familias
completas y menores
ceuta está en el extremo norte de áfrica
y limita con marruecos pero es un
enclave español
por lo tanto territorio europeo y
destino para miles de personas que
buscan una oportunidad de vida en el
continente una frontera que normalmente
es controlada con el apoyo de los
marroquíes pero descuidada a propósito
por marruecos por una atención
diplomática entre ambos países españa
acogió en un hospital al líder del
frente polisario con quien marruecos
mantiene tensiones por el sáhara
occidental'
la respuesta marroquí dejó en medio de
la disputa a miles de personas
provocando una emergencia humanitaria de
la que no se tenía registro españa
respondió con el uso de la fuerza a la
ola de emigrantes en su territorio y
realizó devoluciones express o en
caliente y contrarias al derecho
internacional
una valla que desemboca en el mar y que
separa irremediablemente el norte global
del sur global es la frontera entre
ceuta el enclave español en el norte de
áfrica y marruecos 11 kilómetros
vigilados por las fuerzas de seguridad
españolas y marroquíes su objetivo
impedir la migración irregular desde el
continente africano hacia territorio
español
son casi tres décadas de colaboración
entre españa y marruecos una
colaboración que consiste en
externalizar las políticas migratorias
hacia marruecos para contener la llegada
de emigrantes a cambio de altas sumas de
dinero el primer acuerdo entre los dos
países fue en 1992 un año después se
instalaron las vallas que separan ceuta
de marruecos y en 2002 terminó de
instalarse un sistema de alta tecnología
para controlar la frontera
desde entonces las bayas no han dejado
de crecer esta misma semana el gobierno
español aprobó una partida de 30
millones de euros para este tipo de
cooperación con marruecos
uno de los puntos más polémicos de los
acuerdos son las llamadas devoluciones
en caliente el retorno de emigrantes
inmediatamente después de cruzar
irregularmente la frontera algunos
sistemas de justicia internacionales lo
consideran una práctica ilegal al no
esperar a determinar si los migrantes
tienen derecho a asilo o no antes de
volver a expulsarlos pero que en españa
se permite por los acuerdos bilaterales
con marruecos
que estas devoluciones sólo se
consideran legales si los migrantes son
mayores de edad y se detectan en su
intento de cruzar la frontera
unas premisas que organizaciones de
derechos humanos denuncian que no se han
cumplido con la reciente entrada masiva
de migrantes entre los que se cuentan
1.500 menores de edad de los cuales
muchos según estas denuncias habrían
sido devueltos en caliente a marruecos
en sólo 36 horas más de la mitad de los
que cruzaron unos 4000 estaban de vuelta
en marruecos sin ser individualizados ni
consultados sobre los motivos de su vida
e ignorando posibles peticionarios de
asilo hasta ceuta viajó nuestra
periodista erika olavarría para reportar
lo que pasa allí
pero más de 8000 las personas que
cruzaron desde marruecos a ceuta la
semana pasada durante la crisis
migratoria que afecta a esta ciudad lo
hicieron porque las autoridades
fronterizas marroquíes relajaron los
controles solo les bastaba nadar un poco
para entrar en territorio europeo la
playa del tarajal contiguo a la frontera
se transformó en un verdadero centro de
operaciones de la cruz roja según las
autoridades españolas que se permiten
las expulsiones en caliente esto es
inmediatas de las personas que entran
sin documentación a este país unas siete
mil personas ya han regresado a
marruecos lo cierto es que muchas lo
hicieron por su propia voluntad ya que
aquí no encontraron las maravillas que
escuchaban del lado marroquí lo que
queda sobre todo en ceuta son jóvenes
que deambulan por la ciudad muchos son
menores y están en unos centros que se
han instalado por parte de la ciudad dos
centros y un tercero está en
construcción en el puerto hay que decir
que dos jóvenes murieron en el mar y un
tercero tras caer de 10 metros cuando
intentaba ingresar al puerto de ceuta
todos hablan de una crisis migratoria
pero sobre todo diplomática entre españa
y marruecos después de que madrid
permitiera el ingreso en su territorio
del líder del movimiento independentista
y para atenderse de kobe de 19 en un
hospital de logroño esto despertó el
reclamo de marruecos y si bien madrid se
mantuvo muy cauta finalmente la ministra
de defensa española dijo que este país
no se permitirá un chantaje de parte de
marruecos la unión europea recordó
también a rabat que podría perder las
ayudas que recibe si no controla bien
las fronteras marruecos por su parte
pide una investigación desde madrid'
para saber cómo entró este líder en
territorio español y que se le permita
comparecer frente a la justicia española
donde tiene abiertas dos causas en su
contra por violaciones a los derechos
humanos de disidentes saharauis
se calcula que entre los que cruzaron de
forma irregular hacia ceuta podrían
haber llegado entre 2000 y 3000 menores
sin embargo son datos aproximados de lo
que si se tiene registro es de unos 800
que fueron identificados y a quienes se
les practicaron pruebas de kobe 19
organizaciones como save the children
pidieron que se evalúe caso por caso y
se eviten devoluciones automáticas de
los menores
erika olavarría acompañó a algunos de
los jóvenes en ceuta
hace ya una semana que cientos de
migrantes jóvenes menores o adultos
deambulan por las calles de ceuta
desamparados sin techo ni comida
otros encontraron ayuda en la periferia
de la ciudad
desde comienzos de semana cientos de
ellos llegan a esta casa para ducharse
comer y conseguir ropa le falta un
consorcio y unos calcetines en este
barrio precario una verdadera cadena de
solidaridad se ha creado en torno a
sabah y sus amigos vimos gente ambulando
por la ciudad y dijimos hay que
ayudarlos porque había gente mojada
gente descalza gente desorientada con
hambre y entonces yo y mis amigas que no
es ninguna asociación decidimos ayudar a
estas familias
y varios voluntarios participan en la
preparación del almuerzo
hoy hay bocadillos
toda la comida que hay donde estaba el
producto de donaciones pero ella no se
limita a la comida desde que encuentre
un momento les da consejos en temas
migratorios
y
lejos buscará media luna de fuerza en
efecto una expulsión de españa puede
traerles serios perjuicios hasta cinco
años de prohibición de ingreso al
espacio schengen
[Aplausos]
lo ocurrido en ceuta deja muchos
interrogantes y para eso invitamos a
virginia álvarez ella es responsable de
política interior e investigadora sobre
migraciones de amnistía internacional
señora álvarez muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y yo quiero comenzar
preguntándole lo siguiente la unión
europea hablo de respetar sus fronteras
pero no hablo de la forma en la que
fueron devueltos los migrantes a
marruecos ni tampoco de las devoluciones
en caliente y cómo entender lo que pasó
en ceuta desde el punto de vista de
derechos humanos y que se puede decir de
la postura de europa
bueno pues lo que podemos decir es que
ha habido una vulneración de derechos
humanos precisamente con las expulsiones
en caliente en nuestra opinión
prohibidas por el derecho internacional
muchas de estas personas podrían estar
saliendo de marruecos por persecución y
lo más preocupante es que se han
devuelto menores de edad cuando la
propia propio comité de naciones unidas
para los derechos del niño condenó a
españa en 2019 precisamente por expulsar
en caliente a menores de edad todo esto
no he tenido en consideración por parte
de la unión europea que vemos cómo
utiliza a terceros países para el
control de sus fronteras con con graves
consecuencias también para que los
derechos
señora señora álvarez organizaciones
humanitarias
recalcan que la migración no puede
seguir siendo usada por los gobiernos
como una ficha diplomática y vemos que
nuevamente la necesidad de miles de
personas por migrar fue empleada con
este objetivo
entonces asumen realmente los gobiernos
que la migración es una crisis
humanitaria
los gobiernos
en europa no están asumiendo que la
migración primero es un hecho natural y
luego puede convertirse en una crisis
humanitaria si no se gestiona
correctamente y lo más importante es que
los gobiernos europeos no están
entendiendo también que tienen
obligaciones de derechos humanos y que
no pueden intentar que sean terceros
países los que gestionen sus
obligaciones internacionales de derechos
humanos porque en primer lugar no
solamente no se está trabajando en que
haya vías legales y seguras para que
personas que quieran buscar una mejor
vida puedan acceder a ella sino que de
manera más importante aquellas personas
pueden necesidad de huir por violaciones
de derechos humanos por persecución por
guerra encuentran muchísimos problemas
y lo que está pasando es eso que
terminen arriesgando sus vidas tanto en
el mar como hemos visto por ejemplo en
la ruta más peligrosas que hay es la
ruta entre áfrica y canarias o que
terminen entrando en ceuta en este caso
de esta manera no arriesgando su vida no
hay que olvidar que han muerto dos
personas
señora álvarez están los gobiernos con
sus acciones y respuestas tal vez
avivando sentimientos como el odio la
discriminación y la violencia contra los
migrantes y refugiados
efectivamente ese es un grave problema
que estamos viendo también esta gestión
y también la utilización de palabras que
que no se corresponden como ataque
invasión etcétera etcétera estaba
virando ese sentimiento de racismo y
xenofobia que nos preocupa enormemente y
que impide ver no el sufrimiento de las
personas que están saliendo de sus
países
también cuando uno se salta la ley
también cuando uno se salta a la
legalidad y rompe las reglas de la
humanidad también es un grave peligro no
al que nos estamos enfrentando con este
tipo de actitudes por parte de los
estados donde cualquier cosa vale con
tal de proteger las fronteras señora
virginia álvarez responsable de política
interior e investigadora sobre
migraciones en amnistía internacional
españa gracias por estar con nosotros en
migrantes de france 24
a vosotros muchas gracias a ustedes
también gracias por acompañarnos los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigamos más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]